let me ask you about thomas soul you
mentioned him he's
a colleague and somebody who's an
influence
what
uh in the space of ideas
so what broadly
what impact has he had on your ideas
and um how do you think he shaped the
landscape of ideas in our culture in
general i think tomasuli's in his 90s
now he's been around for a long time
he's still got it he's still going at it
he's still going out the books continue
to come out i think he's a great man
um i think thomas soule
regardless of his race he's black
is one of the
100
most significant economists of the 20th
century
he has chosen as his subject a
substantial part of his subject subject
to investigate
the deep causes and consequences of
racial
disparity of one kind or another
he's written
fundamental books about that
uh many of them he's a social
philosopher
he is a economic historian
he is a combatant in the conflict of
ideas
around how to think about society and
this beyond racial differences although
race has been a big part of what he's
written about he's been critical of
affirmative action and he didn't just
stand back and wag his finger he got
busy looking at the consequences of
affirmative action in societies all
around the world and he's written books
about that
he's been critical of the
narrative about civil rights and racial
inequality he believes in small
government he doesn't think
that efforts to redistribute income have
proved to be the solution to the problem
of
racial disparity
tom has not been honored by the
committee that hands out nobel
recognition in economic science and
probably won't be because he's
controversial and i reckon that that
committee
would be low to encourage the blowback
that they would be sure to receive if
they were to take a
controversial and politically
uh uh focused and expressive black
conservative and honor in that way so i
think another reason is that tom as a
methodological methodological matter
is not especially quantitative he pays
attention to data but he doesn't do
statistical analysis and he doesn't do
modeling
so from a methodological point of view
he's not a cutting edge
uh kind of uh mathematically
sophisticated kind of
quantitatively
statistically oriented but he does
descriptive stuff he writes in a style
uh that is much more like a
social historian that it is like a
like a mathematically trained analytical
economist on the other hand he is an
economist in the chicago school with
milton friedman and george stickler
prominent amongst his teachers
who
takes price theory
which is the
analysis of the interplay of uh market
forces
uh mindful of incentives uh and uh so on
uh to you know
uh implement the basic insights from uh
economic science you know there is no
free lunch i mean there's always going
to be a cost anything that you do and so
on people respond to incentives demand
curve slope downward
um you know competition tends to work
best when people are free to enter and
not and
so on i mean uh that kind of thing but
tom is also a social historian and
uh philosopher in the tradition of a
friedrich phone hayek
one of tom's books i deeply admire
knowledge and decisions is an extension
of the haiki and arguments uh about uh
the
limits of central planning and uh
whatnot
so i think tom seoul thomas soul
african-american
uh born as i understand it in louisiana
uh raised in new york city
uh graduate of harvard college
a military veteran um a phd in economics
from the university of chicago um a
black conservative social scientist of a
very high stature i think he's a great
man and one of the great intellectuals
of the 20th century and you're saying
implicitly deserves a nobel prize
yeah
i i do think so i mean
uh hayek was awarded by the committee uh
gunnar maridol the swedish uh economist
wrote about economic development wrote a
famous two-volume work an american
dilemma about the status of blackstone i
mean i think tom
could be
uh you know put in that company very
easily without any difficulty i agree
danielle kahneman
them so it doesn't have to be new
psychology is he not an economist yeah
um eleanor ostrom uh the political
scientist who was honored in a joint
prize given to her and oliver williamson
15 years ago or so
he could be put in that company really
quite easily
you